ucrania habla de seis mil kilómetros
cuadrados de territorio ganado a rusia
aún tomando esas cifras con prudencia
parece que rusia y sus movimientos
confirman que ucrania está teniendo
éxito en su avance como califica usted
de la situación estamos ante un cambio
de rumbo en la guerra
lo calificó como una situación
sorpresiva en general los analistas
pensaban de que iba a haber un
contraataque ucraniano pero no tenían
realmente referencia para determinar el
grado de éxito de este contraataque fue
mucho más exitoso de lo que uno podía
predecir y esto habla me parece de tres
cosas número uno hay una colosal
negligencia por parte de la inteligencia
de rusa de no haber anticipado un
movimiento de este tipo número 2 ucrania
cambia de táctica y parece que ocupa
infantería movilizada y tropas altamente
ágiles antes que llevar entonces la
guerra a una de desgaste que era la fase
en la que estaba actualmente
desarrollándose y número tres si uno
observa la evidencia que emergen desde
el terreno hay mucho equipamiento en
desuso por parte de las fuerzas rusas lo
que también habla de una ausencia de
resistencia en terreno respecto al
avance ucraniano naturalmente todavía es
muy temprano para saber si esto
significa una nueva fase dentro de la
guerra pero ciertamente es un éxito
tanto político como militar otro de los
puntos importantes dentro de esta
contraofensiva es algo que usted ha
apuntado que rusia está perdiendo mucho
equipamiento militar junto al que
ucrania está recibiendo de naciones
europeas puede ucrania por tanto
utilizar ese armamento en contra de su
enemigo
hoy día ucrania tiene el momentum es
decir tiene el impulso para mantener
este tipo de operaciones pero esto se
suma a un problema muy importante por
parte de rusia vamos a tener el problema
lo que podríamos calificar las 3r es la
falta de reclutamiento la falta de
rotación y la falta de reforzamiento en
ciudades o unidades críticas y esto ha
sido algo que ha estado básicamente
observándose desde junio y que rusia no
ha podido finalmente resolver creo yo
que en el caso de ucrania es cierto hay
algunas unidades militares que
eventualmente pueden ocuparse pero acá
no hay que olvidar de que esto dependió
de la velocidad de las fuerzas
ucranianas del factor sorpresa y por
ende la negligencia de la inteligencia
rusa y también del apoyo de armamento
altamente sofisticado proveniente de
occidente son esos tres factores que
tienen que estar presentes si ucrania
quiere seguir teniendo éxito en la zona
del donbass bueno usted ha hablado del
reclutamiento y reclutamiento dentro de
rusia en donde ya hay voces importantes
díscolas con la posición de putin
algunos piden declarar definitivamente
el estado qué supondría esto para rusia
podría significar una oportunidad del
punto vista de ampliar el volumen de
reclutas posibles pero hay que prestar
mucha atención al hecho de que un
reclutamiento obligatorio no significa
alterar la dinámica de la guerra porque
todos los reclutas deben pasar por
varios meses de entrenamiento para ser
unidades factibles en un escenario de
guerra en otras palabras la ventaja
sigue estando al menos en el mediano
plazo en ucrania y aun cuando la
federación rusa declara formalmente una
guerra no creo que eso modifique a
mediano plazo las dinámicas que hoy día
estamos observando que es un avance
consecutivo con dirección al donbass el
intento de reforzamiento y de control
territorial en lugansk y un retiro cada
vez más progresivo de unidades de
fuerzas armadas rusas